the state department is struggling with
a backlog of passport applications
just as many americans are making plans
to travel abroad
the department says mail delays and
staffing shortages are part of the
problem
adding to that their online booking
system for last minute travel had to be
shut down this week
when third parties were filling up the
slots and selling them
for profit christina raffini is at the
white house this morning with more
christina i know my past part expires at
the end of the year i am concerned
what can you tell us well dana it's not
great news the state department is now
saying it could take up to 18 weeks to
get that passport or renewal complete
and as you mentioned those appointments
are so hard to get the online booking
system those slots were getting scooped
up like super bowl tickets
and getting scalped like them too
in los angeles people pitched tents and
lined up around the block
this is actually our third day here the
first day that i got here for the will
call i showed up at midnight
and waited for the window to open at 7
a.m
but they're not trying to score concert
tickets or a new iphone
what they want is a passport for the
last six months
i have been trying to get my passport
renewed i
have been calling texting emailing carry
a pigeon
that signaling you name it the state
department is trying to clear a backlog
of up to 2 million passports
thanks both to staffing problems during
the pandemic and a sudden surge in newly
vaccinated americans looking to go
abroad we are working
just as expeditiously expeditiously as
we possibly can
knowing that the traveling public
has a legitimate interest
in travel but profiteers also had an
interest
using bots to flood the state
department's online system for urgent or
emergency travel
and booking up all the slots they're
selling multiple
appointments to people for thousands and
thousands of dollars on a website that's
supposed to be helping
each other it's disgusting in response
the state department shut down the
website
now the only way to get an appointment
is to call the passport hotline
and hope someone picks up i am freaking
out because
i call every day to try and get an
answer kelsey and huston rankin applied
for passports in may but only his
arrived
she's worried she might not get her
documents before the imminent departure
of their non-refundable flight
one day i spent roughly four and a half
hours but
typically you can't even get through on
the national passport line because it's
always a busy signal
now the passport office told kelsey they
do think she'll get her documents back
one day before she's set to leave jeff
cutting it close
uh christina if your passport right now
is expiring within the next six months
is the advice that you should send it in
or do you wait
it's really a judgment call if it were
me and this is rafini advice not
official state department advice
i would hold on to it for a little while
and see if the state department can kind
of whittle away this backlog and see if
they can cut that turnaround time down
because if you send it in now you're not
going to get it back until the fall and
if you have to leave the country
you're going to spend a lot of time on
hold i love that newspaper column ask
graffiti
does that mean we can blame raffini if
she's wrong though yes the blame goes
squarely on her all right christina
thank you very much it's